but other people like to you differently
and for some types of questions is much
more useful to try something with an
inequality please ever so slightly
different so rule that off and like
write a little something for method to
what I'm about to do that I'm back to
them but in order to do that you have to
do some other stuff first with the
assumption compassionate okay so he
knows method two now I should point out
because we're proving the same result
you'll find the algebra of what I do to
be remarkably similar like I'm still
going to be doing this sort of chopping
and changing business but the structure
of the logic is kind of different and
I'll point out afterwards what kind of
scenarios you might want to choose this
rather than the way you already know
okay so let's begin actually with
exactly the same assumption can you
write that for I mean it has to be this
this is the N equals K case
and this is where the similarities end
so what I'm going to do with this is
this is a biggie right so one of the
things that we know about inequalities
that we can take advantage of is if I
rephrase this if I put all the terms on
the left of the inequality sign right
what if that leaves us equality will be
on the left hand right hand side rather
it's a zero okay now you might think
well what's the difference like you put
them over there from over there it
doesn't make that big a deal
well it does if what you can get with
over here and when we do the k plus one
case if what you can do is prove that
it's like say a square for instance
because we lose squares are positive
right we know that they can be equal to
zero so but you can deal with that case
separately if you like and so if what
you've got to deal with it like the guts
of your proof it makes it easier to just
deal with something that's positive or
negative then this is a really good
strategy to use in fact improve is
greater than zero I'll be done so here's
my assumption because this is actually
changed I'm going to name it okay
because I assume something and then I
sort of mucked about with it so I'm
going to give it a label right so now I
return back to what I'm trying to do
which is my K plus 1 K so I'm gonna
prove true for N equals k plus 1 let's
write that out 12 to the k plus 1
and again because what I'm trying to do
here is take advantage of I need lots of
things about positive numbers I mean I
kind of did that in the previous proof I
just didn't make it as explicit I'm
going to rewrite this result and rewrite
this one again with everything on the
left-hand side okay so I'm gonna stick
senator maybe here okay so now these are
the goal posts ever so slightly moved so
I'm going off to something different now
and as a consequence I can structure my
proof differently but you don't ask me
about this is second go you the second
ago usually we start off like any one of
these proofs by taking your result and
gone with the left hand side and then
playing around with them now that I have
the right-hand side is 0 I'm in a
perfect position to do that okay so
instead of starting with the assumption
this is method 2 now I'm going to start
with the left hand side of the result
I'm trying to prove which is all the
pieces I needed
okay now remember two things number one
where you're headed
number two what tools you've got to get
there where am I headed
what am I trying to get I just wanted to
be positive just wanted to be positive
if I can manipulate this thing into
something positive then then I'm there
okay that was the first thing that's
where I'm going what tools do I have to
use I've only got one I just have this
assumption right that's all I can really
use okay
so therefore as we've seen before
remember with a series right if you've
got k plus 1 terms then you're gonna
write you're going to write the second
last one because you know you can use
that right in other words you're
consciously writing the root left hand
side of the result right proof in such a
way that the inductive hypothesis just
kind of appears yeah so what I'm gonna
do is I want to muck around with that to
try and find this this is what I'm
hunting for if I can find that in there
somewhere I know that's positive because
that was the assumption right so the
question is where is it okay now you can
see here again and you'll see the
parallels with my previous proof okay
I have 12 of these guys I have 12 months
of 12 to became okay now I do not have
12 lots of these guys okay but if I can
rewrite this do some adding and
subtracting of the same term what will
break apart these terms so there is a 12
I can factorize and try and find this
guy
okay so he's got another new instead of
writing - seven months of seven decay
because that's how many I actually have
in fact I will I will write this line
just so my next line will be a little
more obvious I'm now going to say well
what if I actually had - 12 of them and
not - seven because then they'll be
convenient for me because then I can use
some factorizing of course I don't have
- 12 so what must I add to this to
compensate top still equal yeah I've got
to have five of them
somewhere okay so just like I did before
with my red in my plan okay these two
terms here are equivalent to this term
yep following I'm gonna do exactly the
same thing with the 5 to the K turns if
I imagine that I had 12 of them not 5
and say okay I'm gonna write that but
now I need to compensate by adding
something
what must I have is this feeling
familiar okay so again I've broken one
term into two this guy turned into this
guy and this guy so far so good okay so
now I can actually the point of me
putting twelves where they worked first
of all is so I could factorize right so
this guy here is it's wrong to the K 7
to the K 2 K familiar plus all of this
trailing stuff but the lovely thing
about this slide is that by my
assumption all of this is positive do
you agree like it's 12 times some number
that I've assumed to be positive which
is itself positive okay so therefore at
this point I can say find my assumption
this is all positive and this is all
positive so the whole thing must be
positive right now be careful I have to
justify this right and there are two
pieces so I've got to refer to both of
them so I'm gonna say since firstly I
think it's it's in his self evident just
like we had before of my top line on
that black haired board that this part
is there's nothing you can do to make
that nobody so I'm going to write that
that guy's positive so that's how I know
this what about this bit how do I know
this is positive by the assumption which
you'll notice I haven't invoked here
because now I'm doing it right since
that's positive and became
is positive by assumption so you can see
these proofs despite how similar the
algebra ages they are actually ones the
other one upside down right he started
with the assumption and he only came in
at the very last breath so you can see
I've got the left-hand side is greater
than zero as required that's what I was
trying to get that is the that is the k
plus one case so I now have my last line
right
for off so originally I asked you if so
I said to you I'm gonna show you two
methods now that you've seen - you know
who tell me I just want you to settle
for yourself what you see do you like
better which one fits in your brain
which one sort of is more natural I
think if I don't have like something
obvious jumping out at me I think my
brain defaults for this one okay because
most of the proofs that I do you assume
you don't have to muck around with the
assumption and then you just go ahead
and use it as much as you care so I
think my brain naturally goes here
however as I mentioned sometimes
sometimes what you'd get here when you
stop in it you're like maybe we're gonna
do with this I don't know way to go
right in which case maybe proving its
positive maybe that will give you more
traction and you can have it better go
the question okay the algebra ends up
being the same which is why these are
equivalent I don't know which was longer
what do you think yeah I think the
second one is marginally longer but not
a huge amount like I think they're
roughly equivalent I think like I said
it's which one fits with your brain best
and if the question requires that which
one are you going to go to us okay a key
thing if you see squares in your result
that's a real signal to you hey go for
the positive one because every single
square you find you can already write
that off and say what positive so then I
just worry about the rest